the Saints are now three and two in cam
Jordan who had that tip pick six
yesterday right here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you cam I'm good I'm good
thanks for having me on when was the
last time you scored like that in your
life college movie did you do you have a
one-month account yeah my last game
senior year not a bad way to go out so
we still lost that game so this is even
better we want the game sure
so you tip it you catch it and then you
do like sort of a number one you the man
point you didn't have any celebration
already queued up at that point then
everybody sort of jumped also let you
know what I'm Jimmy Graham in this
situation okay so then you got up and
you dunked it okay
but you do know though is you were
flagged for it well you're not allowed
to touch the to touch it they don't want
you to date they don't want to take time
out cuz I think one time Jimmy did it so
hard they had a breakout like hey hey
again one for my dog jg and now your
team is three and two how different is
this team now than the one that walked
out of the Superdome after your last
game there against the Patriots Cameron
you know like I said I keep saying we've
got a young defense and if people pull
up the facts I'm pretty sure all our
starters we probably have one the
younger defenses in the league but that
being said we've got a hungry defense
and it's learning curve you just had
perhaps to happen real rapidly and again
it's progressing every week and I can't
be upset about you know the way in which
we're progressing for us to have three
touchdowns on defense that's that's a
hell of a thing I don't think I'm like
I've never been a part of it of the
defensive side three touchdowns coming
from them but you know I was a 15 to 16
batted passes another you know add on
another five sack the defense was
rolling
yesterday and you know almost wish there
was more games so we could have more
stat games we we knew had get our hands
up a new to effect the passer we had to
take advantage of we could that's before
we we we move on in your schedule I do
want to go back a little bit here and
keep mining this this story that you
know you guys were finished after the
Patriots just picked you apart and the
defense was the issue how much
soul-searching was going on at the time
Cameron oh no but you know we knew again
we knew we had a young defense we knew
we had a to learn fast you come through
and you have you know Minnesota and you
have a Patriots come come through it's
not like you have enough time to say hey
these are with live bullets feel like we
didn't have a warm-up game there was you
know we were matching efficient offenses
the first two games we got our bearings
and they come out with the winning
Carolina which helps us you know keep
and get that confident booth and roll
into Miami and and to clearly roll into
the third game for our for our winning
um
I guess it's all about it's all about
the season not about what happened you
know the first week is two weeks the
first five weeks I've been the year
we'll look back and say hey this is the
turning point this is how we got back
and there's now you know we're going to
strive to be better well and in terms of
that Miami game in London okay you had a
shutout you pitched a shutout against
Miami in London where Dennis Allen was
fired as coach of the Raiders just a
couple of years before what did it mean
for your team to provide your defensive
coordinator with a shutout in that
situation in that country in that game
camera before our team for our defense
the picture showed out the last time we
did that I think it'd been like you know
four years ago three years ago and for
that to just happen that's great for our
defense for you know VA I'm sure he
meant so much more you know on a
personal level for him as the defensive
player you know you're excited that you
know you can you can support picked out
anyways I mean again it's really you
know three four year stretch runs to
actually happen for me so the part of
Defense's is great feeling
well the team that that Dennis Allen's
Raiders lost to in London was the
Dolphins too so I mean it was all kind
of full circle he didn't say anything to
the team you guys didn't make note of
that or mention it the fact that you
guys know at the end of the day you know
it's about our defense any focuses
solely on our defense so a couple more
minutes here with Cameron Jordan of the
Saints fresh off of a big win against
the Lions yesterday now next up is the
Packers now I'm sure did you see the the
Aaron Rodgers tackle yesterday Cameron
you know would look like just a typical
uh tackle I mean if you're implying
anything of negative connotation I don't
know if I'm going to agree with you no
actually I'm not implying anything but
you being a Cal bear a Harvard of the
West very smart to pick something up
that I was putting down do you think
that was a dirty hit camera because that
is a lot of the conversation today yeah
I mean as a guy who as a defensive
player who always tried to do to make
pressure to create pressure to make a
quarterback uncomfortable the ball had
just been thrown out you know means can
always have this argument of you know
did he have to tackle him or whatever
but as a defensive player your
full-motion you guys go full speed
natural momentum may carry you in today
it wasn't like he picked him up and
slammed him it wasn't anything actually
was just momentum he could have pushed
off and tried to roll out on his own but
why so do you think sometimes it's put
upon you guys as defenders to hear
whistles that are difficult to hear and
hit strike zones that change as you're
trying to hit Cameron oh for sure it's
definitely difficult to hit strike zones
that are difficult to hit you know you
got a you got a quarterback who's
rolling out the pocket you know let's
call it a six six quarterback and he's
wearing white and light blue and all of
a sudden he starts falling and your main
target was chest but now you know
because he's dug down you hit him in the
Helmand you catch a sign for it and
these are things that you know are just
part of the game that you'd hope a
referee
understand but they don't okay couple
more minutes with Cameron Jordan of the
Saints here on the Rich Eisen show so
Brett Hundley first career start how do
you think just first blush you're gonna
be approaching this game I go okay I'm
loving it I'm excited for Brett just
because he's a he comes from the same
high school or mother's as I do okay
you know gotta love their chairman hi
connection okay that being said I love I
love to be the first stack on in his
first game so because of the tear my
connection games gonna be great
anyways I'm just wondering is there any
UCLA Cal hatred here in a way did he
take care of you and you know high
school okay to love the sack Aaron
Rodgers because use from my college you
know love connection there I've got
nothing wrong with the jacket it could
have been Callen Cal violence there
instead it's now Callen on UCLA it all
comes down to it I mean what a big
weekend it was for you for Cal to take
down wazoo like that and then for you to
do what you're doing right now I mean 73
win is you know was there it was there a
third was there a third thing that
happened this weekend and I'm unaware
about in Cameron Jordan's life that went
so well I mean usually good things
happen in threes like that oh I mean no
no no you know we did end up going get
some ice cream as a family I was great
but I was just a family touch so I guess
you know College Pro and Families had
had a great day and then I don't know if
you noticed you see what happened with
Adrian Peterson a hundred and some-odd
yards and more touches over there and
won one game than he did in four games
here and he completely showed out of
course why he called your coach called
it a win-win would you agree with that
trade Cameron as a win-win for everybody
I'm above my pay grade and I'm not I'm
not gonna tiptoe into that one see
you're too smart you keep you keep on
picking up what I put down Cameron I
like it that's why I love having you on
the show please call back anytime and
congrats on on the big pick six and next
time you want to honor
Jimmy Graham just get a little bit more
up so you don't touch the the crossbar
and it's all good
right right right the see that's the new
one I think one goes for the through the
legs lay up and just stay away from that
altogether
that's right trust the process that's
all you need to do right there take care
Cameron that's you bet at cam Jordan 94
the Rich Eisen shown weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like that
download around please just if if it's a
memory thing just delete other apps you
don't need those apps this app the Rich
Eisen show up you need that